as we've already seen in the last few
videos with the war officially starting
in September of 1939 the Axis powers get
momentum through the end of 1939 all the
way into 1940 that was the last video
that we covered and then that takes us
to 1941 and what we're going to see in
1941 which is the focus of this video is
that the Axis powers only seem to gain
more momentum but because of all of that
momentum they perhaps get a little bit
overconfident and stretch themselves or
begin to stretch themselves too thin so
let's think about what happens in 1941
so if we talk about early 1941 or the
spring of 1941 in march bulgaria decides
to join the Axis powers you can imagine
there's a lot of pressure being applied
to them and they kind of see where the
momentum is hey let's let's let's be on
that side so Bulgaria Bulgaria joins the
axis and then in North Africa you might
remember that in 1940 the Allies in
particular the British were able to
defeat the Italians and push them back
into Libya but now in March of 1941 the
Italians get reinforcements Italian
reinforcements and also German
reinforcements under the command of
Rommel the desert Fox famous desert
commander and they are able they are
able to push they are able to push the
British back to the Egyptian border and
they also take siege of the town of
Tobruk now you might have noticed
something that I just draw it the
something that I just drew the supply
lines in the North African campaign are
very very very long and that's part of
the reason why as one side so you know
one side has supply lines as as they
start to make progress and push into
let's say is the Allies make progress
and push into Libya their supply lines
got really long and so the other side
has an easier time resupplying and then
as the axis pushes the Allies back into
Egypt well then their supply lines get
really long and the other side has it
makes it easier for them to resupply and
so North Africa is kind of defined by
this constant back and forth but by
early 1941
it looks like the
the axis is on the offensive they're
able to push the British back into Egypt
lay siege to the town of Tobruk so let
me write this down as North Africa have
all these different shades of red here
let me write this down
North so I'll just write North Africa
right over here or I could say Rommel in
North Africa pushing pushing the British
back and then we get we can start
talking about what happens in the
Balkans and this is still in the spring
as we go into the April of 1941 and just
does a little bit of background here and
frankly I should have covered it a
couple of videos ago but as far back as
1939 actually before World War two
officially started in spring of 1939
Italy actually occupies Albania so this
actually should have already been read
this is in 1939 this is 1939 that this
happens and then at the end of 1940
Italy uses Albania is a base of
operations to try to invade Greece to
try to invade Greece but they are pushed
back and actually one of the reasons why
the British were able to be pushed back
in North Africa is after they were
successful against the Italians most of
the kind of the the bulk of the British
forces were sent to Greece to help
defend Greece at the end of 1940
so this 1939 Albania gets taken over by
Italy and at the end of 1940 October
1940 Greece is invaded so October 1940
so that is right around there Greece is
invaded by Italy but they are then
pushed back but to help the Greeks the
Allies send many of the forces that were
in North Africa after they were
successful against the Italians in Libya
so now as we go into April of 1941 that
was all background remember Albania and
before the war started April 1939
October 1940 was Italy's kind of first
push into Greece and it was a
unsuccessful push into Greece but then
the Greeks get support from the Allies
at North Africa and now as we go into
the Germans start supporting or really
take charge in the Balkans and in Greece
and so with the help of the Germans the
axis is able to take over Yugoslavia and
Greece and start aerial bombardment of
Crete so once again we're not even
halfway through the year in 1941 and we
see a huge swath of Europe is under the
control of the Axis powers
so let me write so the spring
so let me write Yugoslavia Yugoslavia
and Greece Yugoslavia and Greece and
aerial bombardments of Crete and now we
go into the summer the summer of 1941
and this is actually a pivotal move
what's about to happen now you can
imagine that the Axis powers in
particular Hitler are feeling pretty
confident we are only so we're about
we're about that far into the war so
we're not even two years into the war
yet and it looks like the axis is going
to win now you might remember that they
have a pact with the Soviet Union hey
we're going to split a lot of Eastern
Europe into our spheres of influence so
to speak but now Hitler's like well I
think I'm ready to attack and when you
attack the Soviet Union really matters
you do not want to attack the Soviet
Union in the winter this is something or
Russia in the winter Russia is obviously
now kind of the heart of the Soviet
Union that's something Napoleon learned
many military commanders has learned you
do not want to be fighting in Russia
over the winter so summer of 1941 Hitler
figures hey this is this is the axis
chance and so in June he decides to
attack the Soviet Union so Soviet Union
attack attack the Soviet Union so this
is a very very very bold move because
now they're fighting the British
remember that the British are kind of
not not a not a joke to be battling out
here in Western Europe and now they're
going to be taking on the Soviet Union
in the East a major major world power
but
first like always it seems like it's
going well for the Germans by September
they're able to push they're able to
push up all the way to Leningrad so this
is September of 1941 and lay siege and
began laying siege to that town this is
kind of a long bloody siege that happens
there so we're right right now right
about there and most historians would
tell you that this was one of the
mistakes of Adolf Hitler because now he
is stretched very very very thin he has
to fight to world power Soviet Union
Great Britain and the United States
hasn't entered into the war yet and
that's what we're about to get into
because if we go into Asia it was still
in 1941 in 1941 what happens in July so
a little bit after Hitler decides to
start invading the Soviet Union going
back on the pact the non-aggression pact
in July you can imagine the u.s. they
were never pleased with what's been
happening but the envelope the Empire of
Japan has been doing in the Pacific what
do they've been doing in China in
Manchuria or even in in terms of the war
in China the second sino-japanese war
they weren't happy of the Japanese
taking over French Indochina and you
could you know there's a big world power
here in the Empire of Japan there's a
big world power here in the United
States that has a lot of possessions in
the Pacific and so the United States in
July in July of 1941 so remember this is
still all 1941 is the same year decides
to freeze the assets of Japan and
probably the most important part of that
was an oil embargo an oil embargo of
Japan of Japan and this is a big big
deal Japan is fighting a major conflict
with the Chinese it's kind of flexing
its Imperial muscles but it does not
have many natural resources in and of
itself in fact that's one of the reasons
why it's trying to colonize other places
to get more control of natural resources
and now if it's fighting a war it
doesn't have its own oil resources and
now there's an oil embargo
of Japan in the United States at the
time was a major oil producer and
actually even today it's a major oil
producer this was a big deal to the
Japanese because some estimates say that
they only had about two years of
reserves and they were fighting a war
where they might deploy their reserves
even more so you can imagine the
Japanese they want to have their
imperial ambitions they probably want
especially now this is oil embargo they
probably want to take over more natural
resources and they probably want to
knock out the u.s. or at least keep the
US on on its heels so the u.s. can't
stop Japan from doing what it wants to
do so all at once in December December
1941 it's over the course of December
7th and 8th and it gets a little
confusing because a lot of this happens
across the International Dateline but
over the course of December 7th and 8th
Japan goes on the offensive in a major
way in the Pacific over the course of
really several hours at most a day Japan
is able to attack is able to attack
Malaya which is a British possession
it's able to attack Pearl Harbor where
the US Pacific Fleet is it hopes to
knock out the US Pacific Fleet so the US
will have trouble stopping Japan from
doing whatever Japan wants to do in the
u.s. we focus a lot on Pearl Harbor but
this was just one of the attacks in this
whole kind of several hours of attacks
where Japan went on the aggression or
went on on the offensive so we have
Malaya
we have Pearl Harbor we have Singapore
we have Singapore we have Guam we have
Guam we have which was a US military
base you have Wake Island you have the
Philippines which was a u.s. possession
ever since the spanish-american war
you have Hong Kong Hong Kong which is a
British possession and then shortly
after that as you get further into
December so this is when you have kind
of you know Japan attacks Japan
offensive all right Japan offensive and
then as you go into later December the
kind of real prize for Japan was what we
now call Indonesia but
that the the Dutch East Indies on this
map it says Netherlands East Indies but
you got to remember the Netherlands had
been overrun there's a Low Countries
they were already overrun by German
forces so hit so so the Japanese say hey
look there's a lot of resources here
natural resources especially oil let's
go for this and so by the end of 1941
they're also going for the Dutch East
Indies and for Burma so you can imagine
it's a very aggressive very very bold
move on Japan but they were they were
kind of had imperial ambitions they were
short on or they were afraid of kind of
their access to natural resources so
they went for it but obviously one of
the major consequences of this is the
United States was not happy about this
and they were already sympathetic to the
Allies they didn't like what was going
on in Europe either they didn't like
what was going on in China and so that
causes the United States to enter into
World War two - on the side of the
Allies and then the Axis powers to
declare war on the United States which
was a big deal